hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be talking about the risk
of buying an off-plan apartment i
regularly see a lot of property
investors even celebrities footballers
and they're buying into a scheme and it
might be something that's not being
built yet now this is particularly scary
when you're buying off plan and
overseas
i have seen so many people lose money
buying off plan properties when someone
says to my buying off plan oh and it's
overseas i'm just like oh my goodness
because i i've seen it lose money so so
many times now am i saying that off
plans are always bad no am i saying that
overseas is always bad absolutely not
but can it be devastating yes can you
lose money yes you can so this is why
off plan can be a little bit risky
number one
when you're buying an off plan apartment
you don't know
exactly how long it's going to be before
the property is built so many people
have bought off plan or agreed to buy
off plan they're waiting years for the
property to actually be built and it's
completely out of your control because
it depends on the builders it depends on
the on what happens also let's say it
takes two or three years you don't know
what the situation in the economy is
going to be in two or three years so it
might be that in two or three years you
can't get a mortgage it might be that
the market's dropped so it's just a
little bit risky in my opinion agreeing
to buy off plan another thing that's
happened when i've seen people buying
off plan is the developer will be
developing a big apartment block and
he'll sell off plan apartments to maybe
overseas investors or whatever or or
footballers and they'll be sold because
of what they think it's going to look
like because of the cgi's
cgi means a custom computer generated
image so they'll show you what the end
product is going to look like what the
spec is going to be
but you don't actually know for sure if
it's going to be
like what was promised and what they'll
often do and this is something to be
really really mindful of is these
developers will sell you an off plan
apartment in a block and they'll give
you a guaranteed rent for two years so
they'll say right you're buying this
apartment it's a 200 000 pound apartment
and it should be ready in 12 months but
we're not 100 sure it should look like
this here's the computer generated image
but we're not exactly sure of the spec
in there and then you then put down a
deposit a non-refundable deposit you
wait for years and then when it's
finished apartments might be out of
fashion when it's finished it might be a
little bit more than you thought you
might struggle to get a mortgage who
knows but they'll give you a guaranteed
rent and they'll say for two years we'll
give you a thousand pounds a month rent
okay so you think okay that sounds good
and you work the return on investment
out on that figure but what often
happens is
the going rent isn't one thousand pounds
a month
the developer has over inflated
the rent really the rent 700 quid
but the developer has worked out that
they can afford to subsidize the
difference
and basically make up the 300 pounds a
month for two years what's that well 300
pounds a month for two years is three
thousand six times two it's about seven
thousand two hundred pounds
so in their mind they've sold you an
apartment for two hundred thousand
pounds off plan they've got your money
up front for the deposit it might not be
ready for another few years who knows
they've told you that they'll guarantee
that the rent is going to be a grand a
month for the first two years in your
mind you're thinking after two years you
might be able to get more rent
they've guaranteed a grand but it's
really only 700. so they're subsidizing
the difference
and they're selling you an over-inflated
product
you work out the yield is good but
actually after two years you realize the
rent is only 700 pounds so
i don't really necessarily think that
off plan is a good idea unless you
really know what you're doing but the
problem with off plan is a lot of people
that buy off plan tend to be investors
that don't know what they're doing
they get sucked in by the guaranteed
rent for two years
they get suckered in by computer
generated images and they like the idea
of owning something new and shiny but
actually are these off plan apartments
necessarily a good investment or often
they are not and the reason overseas
investors get so suck it in is because
it's like oh i want to own something in
jamaica oh
but when you don't know the area there's
honestly there's so many problems that
can happen and the rules and the laws
can be different so again you get
suckered in oh it looks brilliant i want
to buy something in the caribbean and
it's going to look like this and you see
the images and it's all in motion
and you're trying to cut corners because
you think oh it's all done for me and
it's guaranteed but when you're trying
to cut corners and you're buying based
on emotion
uh just be really careful so that is my
warning to anybody thinking about buying
an off plan
or even worse off plan overseas
apartment or new build property now
again flips ideas there can be good
sides uh i'm not saying it's always bad
but just be careful hope this video
helps i'll see you next time